remember i said the worst matchup for
khabib is brian
remember that
sorry bro like i disagree and then
[ __ ] could be gonna beat me and then
you'd be like i [ __ ] you could be
nothing
no but what do you think about it
because khabib yeah
this is the only reason why i say this
and i and
as a martial artist martial artist i
would love that fight for myself yeah of
course because i know it would no you
want to test yourself but not not even
detest yourself
bro
this is the reason why he's been
wrestling his entire life and he's been
on top of people his entire life yeah
my entire life i've had the gracies on
top and beating the [ __ ] out of me yeah
big and
for the grappling aspect that's it for
this put it this way even if it's like i
wouldn't like all right let's say [ __ ]
you brian he'll never fight like i would
just love to grapple with the guy and
it's more of like a it doesn't come from
a place of of oh i want to fight him or
beat him nothing
it comes from a place like yo
i want to see what i have yeah of course
and because this guy plays just like we
we dance the same rhythm in different
ways
we [ __ ] he's a top guy i'm a bottom
guy
and
but people forget people forget look
even though even though he even though
he's just gone
even though he's such a dominant
wrestler his jiu jitsu from the bottom
as well as his all of his other
submissions they're khabib's all of his
submissions are they're very good no i'm
not saying they're not he's not
what i'm saying what i'm saying though
is he's just as good off the bottom as
he's talking about guys
but no one can put no one but people
have and that's the thing like how do
you know
i've trained with him for seven years
captain aka one of them but you know i
cornered him for four or four or five of
his fights when he starts calling him so
i guess i've trained with him for years
he's not he's gonna spring or take out
from the bottom
no not for the no but he's not he also
not someone that stays there he doesn't
hit submission from the bottom where he
does he sweeps you to get on top and
that's how he gets yourself he is not in
terms of submissions from the bottom
that's not his game but let's not let's
not be mistaken and that's what i'm
saying
is not the same
it's been proven it's not the same okay
and i'm not trying to just i'm not
trying to discredit jiu jitsu but the
samo fighters they've been doing jiu
jitsu for
decades for the generations of this okay
sure has been around but just to just
one aspect of fighting [ __ ] is a
mixture of what mma was before yeah
we're just saying khabib on top brian on
the bottom yes brian also doesn't move
like traditionally i i i can understand
i don't have normal yeah jiu jitsu
behaviors tell him about your guilt like
i have
read it's like yo right about that
hey i'm sorry hey i'm
bro you have your opinion i got mine
like and and when i say like that like i
said earlier you might as well i didn't
even i didn't i didn't even i didn't
even know you [ __ ] were you know yeah
i get it i don't know [ __ ] about that
that's all people i get it no no no no
no like i didn't know you train with
them bro i don't know anything about
knowing what gyms are yeah yeah i got
you i don't watch fights like pedro's
dude
like my ocean is just like what if
there's a guy that i would love to fight
he [ __ ] me up or not yeah it would be
him
of course i i only said that someone
said hey
can you fight the beat but it will never
happen so it will never happen i will
never say no it will never happen
listen
when i watch his interviews i [ __ ] with
what he said yeah everyone
is legit when he speaks
people listen i [ __ ] like what he
says i love what he's about i love the
way he conducts himself i love the [ __ ]
that he says he's a true pro he's a true
pro and he's he's in my opinion
like
i like to i would want to think yeah
like him because he would be
some
and the way situations would happen
about it
no no the way he is i'm talking about it
bro
and i go damn bro like he said what i
thought but he he said it better yeah
yeah he's not yeah he's
a good person he does a lot of good
stuff for his community yeah he's doing
a lot of great stuff for like dude all
the guys that he's trained with these
come up and even when i saw like sure
that they're connor just taking care of
us even when i saw the condition and i
saw like
uh
what his father said yeah i don't know
if you saw the interview yeah yeah yeah
he goes i'll have him over in my house
that's when i said you know what that's
where like yeah
that's why every time he says something
he'll ask him about stuff and he goes
he'll explain his thoughts and he goes
that's just my opinion yeah that's from
my opinion yeah i think i think that's
why the connor stuff's so cringy it's
like god dude you're [ __ ] with a good
guy yeah yeah and he beat you dude yeah
that's the other thing yeah i'm just i'm
a fan of the guy yeah he's not it's hard
not to be though it's hard not to be
like when we were both in ufc i was like
i might fight him so like
and then like
after that like the more i watch i go
dude like i [ __ ] with this he's a good
dude like he's a good dude but if you
guys do if you guys do do a submission
thing
you and i bet on it huh